today we're talking about how OverWatch
2 is limiting new players and how
multiverses is doubling the leveling
requirement
let's start with the good news in
OverWatch 2 all original Heroes will be
free for new players now for the man
news the OG roster will be locked for
new players until they hit certain
Milestones but won't we all be new
players because the game is new
nope according to Blizzard's blog posts
new players are those who are making
their accounts post OverWatch to launch
and aren't those who already have an
account in OverWatch new players will
first begin with a restricted pool of
modes and heroes in the first half of
OverWatch 2's first time user experience
they'll unlock all the modes in the
second half players will progressively
obtain original OverWatch Heroes but get
this it's gonna take 100 matches to
unlock all of them first time user
experience will not apply to players
entering in a group however so new
players can play any mode with the
exception of competitive with their
friends if they so desire access to
competitive requires new players to
First Win 50 quick play matches this is
to make sure players are ready for the
higher skill level required of
competitive and to not discourage
veteran OverWatch players who have new
players on their team requiring players
to First Win matches in order to get
into competitive will also make it
harder for Griefers and cheaters to jump
into competitive matches so what do you
think about all of this my initial
thought is this was a good way to hand
hold newbies into like the best
experience possible but at the same time
I do think an optional version of this
would work as well a slow path for those
who want to go one by one and really
learn the characters and the different
modes but then a fast track for those
who are familiar with OverWatch one
maybe they played a lot on like their
older brother or sister's account or
their friends accounts and they just
didn't have one of their own but at the
same time that specific pool of people
do have enough time to make an account
before the game actually comes out so I
I don't know I don't know but sticking
with the hero slash character talk if
you've been enjoying the character
leveling and multiverses I'm sorry the
game's 1.03 patch will increase the
amount of experience needed to level up
a single character between levels 3 and
15 as the developers found that quote
players could get to level 15 of the
Mastery track too quickly multiverses
fans reacted to the change over on the
game's subreddit with memes and long
threads about whether or not this is a
positive change one of the suggestions a
handful of users think would help the
experience is the addition of more
rewards after level 15. another user
suggested making a character's gameplay
related perks complete at level 10 and
make everything else above 10 cosmetic
or currency related I know there's a
bunch of people out there that love a
grind and people that hate a grind so
which pool do you fall into and is this
Change Gonna push you away from
multiverses let me know in the comments
the good news comes in the form of Rick
Sanchez from Rick and Morty joining the
roster and Shaggy of Scooby-Doo becoming
free to everyone who completes the
in-game tutorial the sandwich loving
hippie will replace the previous free
character wonder woman who can now be
purchased with in-game gold or galimium
the game's premium currency for all of
the patch notes make sure you head on
over to gamespot.com I'll toss a link to
the article in the description but okay
if you made it this far into the video
hit the comment section and tell me your
favorite game but only use emojis I'll
see you tomorrow
foreign